bio demande c'est squeeze aujourd'hui on
se retrouve avec l'opus rick ici
présents sur aliens isolation ça nous
fait plaisir
adri puisque la le menu est un peu buggé
je vous la vous voilà donc a eu un dlc
du mode survie voilà vous pouvez juge
jouer un mandat dans un seul niveau et
maintenant on peut jouer quelqu'un du
nom de ron s'en remet à des équipements
revolver pistolet à clous à doha où il a
carrément rock et c'est parti on va
s'armer jusqu'aux dents olala ça me fait
plaisir d'être de retour dans ce jeu
vous imaginez même pas à quel point ba
c'est nickel - oculus bonne je dois
jouer la tête de travers c'est parfait
ça me plaît énormément à la normale
plein de trucs un mas un peu partout
avant de tracer faucon itunes ça c'est
la maps à un gros un grand rectangle
noir bas c'est parfait merci pour toutes
ces indications riches
bon vous savez quoi emballer un mode
ballesta allez c'est parti à on est sur
le cul de son empreinte sur à
l'isolation c'est pas pour attendre 20
minutes avant de partir tout indique moi
aussi les nvision jeunes radars on est
content d un domaine où la lienne l'a
fait savoir aussi au hockey sa commande
directe on est dans le bain non non
c'est pas ça je veux faire mais s'il met
au passé comme ça attendez y avait un
conduit à passer par le conduit moi ça
me fait plaisir à la fois mais pas trop
non plus de retourner sur ce jeu pas
contre mon couilles kiffan est où là
j'ai appris il ya pas si longtemps que
ça que l'haleine pouvait venir nous
buter dans les conduits en fait est ce
qu on sait juste voilé là mais que dalle
il ya un grand noir avec marquez démerde
toi fdp et c'est la mort qui va tu as à
pau
je n'ose pas sortir vous avez dit il
peut bien dans les conduits en dehors qc
cent fois pire sur les connaissez plus
sortir son haleine a bomb a fait part
mais arrivé à lons n'est ce pas bâton 16
pas ma part une petite défaite dès le
début non mais oh c'est parti est par
contre je suis vraiment finir avec un
[ __ ] torticolis l'aspect une blague
oh mais c'est sérieux te cacher c'est un
accouchement bats les couilles
brouillard dont ils ne savent pas vu non
ça nous a plu
[Applaudissements]
french kiss prensky avec un alien j'ai
vu ça et oui je dis french kitch non
mais il est hyper agressif roi mais
s'arrête jamais il n'a pas pris de
vacances lui depuis ses trois semaines
se ressent joual ya 90 ans le but du
mode survie puisque je n'ai pas dit
c'est d'aller à un point a vers un point
b sans mourir le plein spleen en poésie
voilà ce que je trouve dingue c'est
qu'on n'a même pas de lance-flammes quoi
année d'aider la des bols déçu pour
manger ça y en a mais les lensois mais
ils sont où la discrétion avant tout
messieurs dames on va passer par la
gauche comme ça pourquoi défaut espace
ça c'est un bug madame si encore l'air
l'interface et les là bas il est
descendu il s'en dit les conduits et ça
tombe bien parce que nous on est dedans
attendait il est pas loin les palois est
jaloux snif comme ça sans déconner plus
tard des personnalités doivent bien
transpiré quoi malheureusement c'est par
là qu'on doit aller donc on n'a pas trop
le choix de toute manière voiture on y
va c'est parti on prend notre courage à
deux mains
enfin c'est horrible jantes et le
moindre bruit j'entends j'aime ce que
j'aime faire poignarder à tout moment
ces trois mois il ya eu et un autre nous
mon gars tu peux rien faire tu le sais
évidemment un truc du son j'ai plein de
créer un truc de son gré du son nom ses
cachets j'ai un revolver dans les mains
sinon dans son ensemble c'est comme tu
le regardes oui oh oh oh oh yeah ça dit
ou pas oui lance flammes il faut
absolument que je trouve le lance flamme
est juste là il voit juste nos chevaux
dépassé lui
oh là là la chance la chance pour une
vie sans aliens je donnerais n'importe
quoi oh pardon attendait pour une vie
sans avenir nous a attendus à une
chanson je suis un peu dégoûté
tout le monde les voit tous des mois de
courage ok nouvelle pièce papa mais
c'est bien ça des fois ya des flashes
noah mais ça c'est scandaleux ça ça je
sais pas qu'électricien qui accable et
tous secteurs mais il faut vraiment le
licencier a dans un premier temps
a vite fait place au pire on non roche
des tiroirs il va nous voir dans ces
bruits nous cache un peu les tiroirs à
les choses se compliquent
allez remonte là où il ya plein de
choses ya de l'eau il ya des femmes des
femmes des aliens féminin et oui j'ai
tellement peur je me touche un poil que
j'ai sur le coin de la bouche totalement
ridicule je rappelle que but c'est de
faire ça je veux rapidement paul sait
pas ce qu'on peut dire qu'on sera
dernier mondial on a revu nos débuts
mechiche à dieu non rang pour ans qu'on
ait caché comme un steak haché
hier derrière derrière des ne trouvera
pas vous dire qui ne trouvera pas
tournée tu as le tournis à bientôt
ça a marché pour des ces méga show ils
doutent d'un truc là nous a sniffé c'est
sûr a transpiré [ __ ] il le sort après
je sais que tu as peur je ne sais pas oh
là là mais c'est génial cette technique
sont est connu il ya toujours ce genre
de poulets a entre temps par contre il
n'a pas fait de muscu c'est un peu
triste mais bon c'est par la regarde et
vois la fac j'ai ri gauche tout à
l'heure mais bien là on est bien on est
calme on est d'où hop la nouvelle pièce
alors ramassé lance flammes
je vous avais dit quoi aborder qu'est ce
que je vous avais dit il est mort il
était posé devant son ciné boom films 3d
réalistes merde je l'avais sur visage
on a maintenant on était sur un bon
feeling c'était vraiment bien et je me
suis blessé le froid avec l'oculus juste
là s'intéresse quelqu'un donc c'est
gauche droite gauche devant derrière
voilà où ils arrivent ils arrivent là il
est descendu à gauche lesquels on doit
aller eh ben on va ton petit pas
tranquillement penser qu'il a envie de
me refaire un french kiss comme ta leurs
ges j'adresse à franchement c'est la
bleue avoir plus vraiment mer mais
affirme toi faire n'importe quoi c'est
bon il est remonté on va y aller alors
c'est pas le monde s'est gratté les
[ __ ] a fauché il n'est plus là elle et
la [ __ ] eh ben on rejoue au tournicoti
tournicoton voyez il aime tout ce que je
vous propose les french kiss et
activités un petit peu sportive là où il
faut se trouver tout ça ça lui plaît sur
les choses qu'ils adorent ils volent
regarder le message qu'on prend il
devient un petit peu grassouillet la
paix de la petite brioche bat wil chasse
plus perçoit plus personne et sur le jeu
alors forcément c'est le moment de s'en
aller non mais moi mais j'ai des landes
courage mais me stoppe à chaque fois il
sans quoi le problème
harder corps âme est décidément son jeu
préféré allez on y va
oh [ __ ] les plus en plus fort mais
progresse vital trop regarder il chausse
du 58 ça que la chose du 178 apparemment
bas il ya peut-être des bonnets pour que
finalement ça paye peut-être dès que
connues au maire merde merde oui mais ça
paie d'abord au nom j'ai raté notre
deuxième frêche qui suis désolé oh la
vache il me tend cet essai sera le bon
j'en suis convaincu et je crois qu'ils
ont des difficultés et universel pour
tout le monde dans la difficulté
y'a pas de mots difficulté squeeze c'est
à dire un mot doux c'est extrêmement
simple voire même un mobile n'est pas d'
alien enfin pas d' alien pas de french
kiss donc bon finalement fait bien
tourner sans déconner je descends imac
réussir elle joue la pop chantant
il est tout prêt du tout près parfum de
tournicoter alors il a gagné une manche
dans les gagner une manière ex-aequo
mais j'avoue que je préfère jouer à des
jeux comme ça avec d'autres gens que cet
alien c'est bon il est reparti c'est le
moment ou jamais non j'm'en fous de
games lance la [ __ ] mais des problèmes
4 la bienvenue et inspecte avant de te
bouffer alors là on va passer à avoir
deux fois c'est moi qui vous le dis
c'est que je les vois pas très bien de
ne plus lui ces petits cons là au plat
voila voila tu mets bien ta queue comme
ça tu connais bien on foetus version
aliens bébé faut rétablir le courant ont
rétabli le courant et voilà encore ce
[ __ ] [ __ ] électricien qui a fait
n'importe quoi c'est scandaleux ça c'est
un scandale je pense que ça va être de
l'autre côté je me sens si seul et non
aînés face aux personnes qui m'aiment à
peu près sûr les gens décédés
ce qui me donne des trucs l'allier la
déserter vous avez couple est reparti il
est plus là l'a dit j'en ai marre de ce
métier ça suffit je change à regarder
c'est pas ça c'est pas ça regarde et que
vois-je ok s'activent toutes les
sécurités très bien comme ça on est bien
fermée avec lui c'est parfait tu as
encore dit la porte est grande ouverte
un mauvais plan alors qu'est ce qui t'a
fait le problème c'est que la résolution
no cuchery fait tellement ridicule que
je vois pas quoi y'a des trucs indiqué
par exemple vous avez rétabli le courant
vous allez mourir
vous êtes nuls forme ça je vois pas ben
voilà c'est peut-être juste là bah oui
[ __ ] mais cas de baby lé roumain on a
l'habitude ça vous
petite poche du brouhaha tensions
poindre ici loupé la discrétion ça c'est
moi même battu avec serait lancé une
grosse musique techno
oh non non non pas 2 x 2 x 2 x 2 x enfin
papa dtc et jaune aliens à la petite que
va bientôt
ce n'est pas des aliens sait plus
comment s'appelle puisque je suis
stressé hockey howie une tour de
contrôle c'est ça nous coupe du monde
toujours les bbb vous allez pouvoir vous
enfuir dans une autre galaxie pouvoir
faible très bien bas la galaxie très
proches alors avoir la salle d'à côté
par exemple
non non non non non non non non non j'en
peux plus et les cardiaques les gens je
vous cache pas que j'ai une gerbe
monumental 7 oculus des cas un homme
extrêmement mal sur certains jeux et là
c'est le cas voyant en plein plein
dégagement de transpiration et de tout
ça j'espère qu'avec ce petit retour sur
les désolations vous a plu moi bien sûr
que oui même si je vous avoue que justin
extrêmement mal aujourd'hui voilà je me
fasse les petits tours pour pour rien ça
sert à rien encore merci d'avoir regardé
la vidéo n'hésitez pas à aller mais si
vous voulez faire un french kiss vous
aussi en alien avec site de mâchoire et
tout ça peut bon ok ça n'arrivera jamais
à se tourner très vite dans une nouvelle
vidéo chat au monde
pis
[Musique]